we are just five days away from the
final episode of the People vs OJ
Simpson's miniseries has been a big hit
for FX even though we all know how it's
gonna turn out right and the cast has
got a lot to celebrate and they did just
that last night in New York a special
screening John Travolta brought wife
Kelly Preston out to celebrate next
Tuesday's finale that millions of fans
and critics are dying to see today's the
day he told me years ago that the
highest critical claim I would have ever
gotten was playing an older eccentric
lawyer you know I would say really
but shocker there's one person not
watching the guy playing OJ no no I
won't watch it be it'll be a minute I
have to step away from this time period
in my life this scene had viewers going
crazy on Twitter was there really a
relationship between the members of OJ's
prosecution team I have my theories and
my thoughts about what I think was
happening there he talks about it in
this book in contempt did they do the
due he leaves that unsaid I think it's
just the agreement that they came up
with between the two of them
he never had any confirmation from
either one of them so if we didn't have
any direct concrete proof we were not
going to actually give it to the
audience as if it were a fact even
watching it I am obsessed in it Tina Fey
was fangirling all over the couch so I
was like I need to fill out my paperwork
for the Emmys so I can vote first
sterling and John Travolta